mais elle
le temps d'une journée ces trois amis se
transforme en mère noël
elle distribue plus de 320 cadeaux
partout dans la région
on a 7 phone à faire ça vous pouvez pas
vous imaginer les gens qui viennent ici
sont dans un état d'esprit différent de
quand tu es rencontres n'importe où
ailleurs
il ya tout de même mot d'ordre a
respecté ici la discrétion car les
généreux donateurs choisissent un enfant
qui ne connaîtront jamais line ont été
modifiés pour préserver leur anonymat
jason les verts qui aimeraient bien
assister à la remise de cadeaux aux
anges où sont ils beaucoup de ces
enfants là qui n'ont pas la chance d
avoir des noëls en contact comme nos
enfants nous vous pas top des fois dans
la même situation financière n'est sûr
j'aimerais sauver ce sont des
travailleurs sociaux qui sélectionne des
jeunes familles démunies ou qui vivent
une situation difficile
c'est des enfants qu'on voit
quotidiennement fait qu'on peut voir un
petit peu aussi question dans leur boîte
à lunch
qu'est ce qu'ils mangent à l'école le
midi on avait beaucoup de larmes
coulaient des très bas nous autant
pleuré monture interne et ici aussi il
ay merci de la haute gaspésie ne manque
pas de famille dans le besoin
bien des municipalités ont un indice de
développement parmi les plus bas au
québec chantal pellerin ancien quelque
chose c'est d'être un bon me finalement
solar souvent leur détresse leur
tristesse aussi comment on chante on
rien faire ni raison là comme celle-là
on s'entraîne normalement these
répondent deux rendez vous importants
après trois ans elle espère transmettre
leur passion à d'autres bénévoles qui à
leur tour les remplaceront pour jouer au
père ou à la mère noël deux jours ici
jean françois deschênes radio-canada
cash